for the first time the people of Moscow
have had a taste of what they've been
living through all war in Ukraine
the outskirts of the Russian Capital
under assault from drones
crashing into open land or damaging
buildings including this apartment Block
in a well-off suburb where members of
moscow's Elites have homes ordinary
residents told Sky News they were deeply
alarmed by the attacks
it's not good at all it's bad yes of
course they should be down to all the
drones it's Moscow not a Border Town
this should not happen but she more once
deadly children the question is why it
reached here I mean there should have
been some kind of air defense for all
this that's all it's scary
the attacks have prompted this
accusation from Vladimir Putin but also
an admission that Russia's defenses
could be improved education this is of
course a clear sign of terrorist
activities first I want to say that the
Moscow air defense system worked in the
regular way although there are things
for us to work on
we know multiple different types of
drones were used in the attack according
to defense intelligence firm Jane's this
one resembles the structure of a
so-called Beaver UAV which has a
distinctive shape this type of drone is
previously featured and post shared by a
Ukrainian influencer now Sky News has
verified four places where drones either
crashed or appeared have been shot down
and these are another four places where
Russian authorities say they came down
multiple air defense systems ring the
Russian capital and these are just some
that we know about Moscow says they were
successful in shooting down all of the
drones to get that far they would have
had to have flown at least 260 miles
from Ukraine unless of course they were
launched from within Russia this expert
says it's possible that Russia launched
the attack on itself well on the one
side this could be a Russian false flag
exercise yet again aim to drum up
Russian support for the war and perhaps
a future draft that is coming in
response to the Ukrainian offensive now
on the other side of this it could be
Ukraine we know they have the technical
capabilities to launch such a strike but
do I think they deliberately aim to
Target civilian centers no Ukraine has
only ever targeted military industrial
and energy infrastructure and the only
reason they hit civilian sites is
because they were shot down by Russian
air defenses
others say Ukraine launched the drones
in Revenge for this Russia's Relentless
attacks on its cities now happening
night and day ukrainians woke up to yet
another morning of aerial assaults that
authorities say killed more than four
people
Ukraine has promised allies not to
attack Targets in Russia if it is behind
this it could alienate to the West
although the UK for now is standing
strong in its support Ukraine does have
the legitimate right to defend itself it
has a legitimate right to do so within
its own borders of course but it does
also have the right to project Force
Beyond its borders as Ukraine's drone
Wars escalate it may believe it had no
choice but to retaliate Dominic wagorn
Sky News